-Welcome, welcome.
Thank you all for being here.
I appreciate this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is clearly --
Yeah, do you just get
standing ovations
wherever you guys go?
-Yeah.
-It's been a while.
-Yeah, yeah.
I'm so happy you guys are here.
And I know people have been
trying to get you guys together
to reunite for a long time.
Why now?
-Jason Reitman
wrote a great script.
So full of heart
and going right back
to the first two movies and
its DNA and its heart and soul.
And we just read it and thought,
"You know,
this is the right time
and this is
the right way to do it."
-Jason is the son of the
original director, Ivan Reitman,
and Jason's made some
great movies on his own.
And he had his
own take on --
Because he grew up as a child
of the "Ghostbusters"
sort of in a way.
He had something he thought
would work as a good story,
and we all agreed
that he got it, yeah.
-Do you remember him
as a kid on set?
-He was a pain in the ass.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait a second. Oh, my God.
-He was directing back then.
-So was his sister, Catherine.
She was a pain, too.
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
-Now they're big stars.
She's on "Workin' Moms."
-She directs "Workin' Moms."
And she's very good.
-Ernie, you're a
classically trained actor,
and you get on set with --
-Yeah, what are you
doing with us?
-How did you -- What did you
think about these guys?
Because you have
Bill, Dan, and Harold Ramis
came from a comedy background.
-Yeah, no, it's --
You know,
I'm always looking for a job,
so I was happy to be working.
But, yeah, no,
they were always very welcoming.
And, you know, it took a minute
to sort of catch up, I guess,
because --
-They knew each other, yeah.
Did you get in trouble
together, you guys?
-Um, we had a wonderful night,
I remember,
where we had available to us
some New York police motorcycles
because we were shooting Uptown.
And, so, Billy and I decided
we'd would like to take
a little ride around
Central Park.
And we grabbed those bikes
and screamed all over the park.
It was closed for some reason.
And we were just --
You know, lights and sirens
and, you know,
pulling over pedestrians.
-Well, we were helping out,
you know.
-Oh, wow.
-That's right, yeah.
-That's very thoughtful
of you guys.
-You know, auxiliary.
You know,
kind of like volunteers.
-That's so thoughtful.
And, Ernie, what do you
do when that happens?
Do you just let it ride?
-Yeah, I just ride.
I just watch.
-You sit back.
-You know, I'm here, yeah.
-Bill and Dan, this building,
I know, means a lot to you.
This is where you
got your start,
"Saturday Night Live."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, a lot of -- Basically.
I know you...
-And still going.
-With great people
and great writing.
And this season,
they're really hitting it.
-I remember, Dan,
when I first started,
you came into the office.
And I just even
heard your voice,
and I was like,
"That's Dan Aykroyd."
You just hear Dan Aykroyd's
voice through the office.
You're like,
"You're the new kid?"
You're like, "Come with me.
I'll show you around."
And he took me
to the 11th floor.
-Mm-hmm.
-We crawled --
-We went through a window
and went to the garden.
-Yeah, we crawled
through a window
and ended up in the garden.
-Yeah. That's right.
You can go to the 11th floor.
And you pass
the secretary's desk,
and she goes, "What are you..."
And you go through
the window next to her desk
and you're out on the
roof garden overlooking
St. Patrick's Cathedral
and all that.
-Did you used to hang there?
-Well, you were helping out,
and I appreciate that.
-Yeah, I was.
I was just helping out.
That's all I was doing.
-Like, you couldn't believe
that there was --
Why would anybody be in the
elevator when you could be on
this beautiful
garden overlooking St. Pat's?
You know, it was pretty nice.
-Can you still go up there?
I think they might have
closed it.
-Yeah, you can still
do everything.
-Yeah. It's still there.
-You just got to have
a little key.
-Yeah.
-Unlock the window or break it.
Because they repair
everything around here.
It's great.
-Dan, can you talk about
"Ghostbusters,"
where the idea came from?
-Well, you know,
my great-grandfather Sam
was a dentist up there in
Kingston, Ontario.
So, sometimes, with not much to
do in the winter.
he began to research
spiritualism in the 1920s.
And he was really into
the concept of
the idea of mediumship,
that the consciousness survives
after death.
Not only the soul,
but the consciousness
survives after death.
So, he had all these journals
sitting around the house.
And I was sitting in the
old séance room
one afternoon in the summer
and I was reading some of
the journals that he was writing
and I just thought,
"You know, would it be good to
do an old-style
Bob Hope, Bing Crosby,
Abbott and Costello,
Bowery Boys-style comedy,
like they used to do
in the '30s?"
You know, ghost breakers and
ghost chasers.
And I thought if
you used all of the research
that's really been done and
combined it together,
we could have something there.
Now, no one knew what
ectoplasm was
before the
"Ghostbusters" movie, right?
Now millions of people know
what ectoplasm is now.
And all over the country now,
in every county,
there is a ghost-busting society
with the equipment.
They go out.
There's all kinds of shows of
the paranormal
and the supernatural.
That's all from my
great-grandfather's work
and the movie
we all put together.
I believe that's true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's fantastic.
-Dan, this is
late-night television.
People are going to look for a
number on the lower third
of the screen here to call
about this thing.
You don't say that kind of stuff
late at night.
-Dan, was it true that
the script was like
300 pages or something?
-It wasn't. No, it was about --
-900 pages.
-Thank you, Bill.
-No, it was about --
That was the other script.
This one was about 150.
And, you know, it had ecto.
It had Stay-Puft.
It had the packs.
It had the concept.
It just -- It was --
It took place
in another dimension,
rather than our dimension.
And, so, it was Harold and Ivan
that sort of said,
"Let's get it to something
that we know.
Let's get it to something
we can identify with."
And that's ghostbusting in
New York City.
But all of the elements were
in the first script
that we eventually
ended up using.
Yeah.
-Sorry. That made me laugh.
-"Ghostbusting in
New York City."
-"How about we do it on Earth?"
Yeah, that's a great idea.
-Well, that was it, you see?
-Something we all know --
ghostbusting here in the
Tri-State Area.
-Yeah.
Yeah.
-The name "Ghostbusters" wasn't
originally -- Right?
It wasn't cleared or --
-We called the movie
"Ghostbusters,"
but there was a show on
Taft Broadcasting
with Larry Storch.
Remember from "F Troop"?
-Yes, of course.
-And Forrest Tucker? Yeah.
And it was called
"Ghost Busters."
And they had a gorilla that went
around busting ghosts, you know.
-I love that.
-It wasn't like the technology
that we had or anything,
but it was just the title.
So we had to pay
to get the title.
-Yeah.
-Actually,
you brought a clip of --
This is Dan, Bill,
and Harold Ramis
shooting a scene for
"Ghostbusters"
before you settled on
the name "Ghostbusters."
Look at this.
-Are you troubled by
strange noises in the night?
-Do you experience feelings of
dread in your basement or attic?
-Have you or
any of your family ever seen
a spook, specter, or ghost?
-If the answer is "yes,"
then don't wait another minute.
Pick up your phone
and call the professionals.
-Ghost-stoppers!
-Take 4.
-Take 4!
-If the answer is "yes,"
then don't wait another minute.
Pick up your phone
and call the professionals.
-Ghost-blasters!
-Yeah. Ghost-blasters!
When we come back,
we're going to talk about
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife."
More with Bill Murray,
Dan Aykroyd, Ernie Hudson!
Come on back!
♪♪
-♪ In the cool of the evening ♪
♪ When everything is
feelin' kind of groovy ♪
♪ And I call you up and ask you
if you want to come and
come and see a movie ♪
♪ Well, first, you say "no" ♪
♪ You got plans for the night ♪
♪ And then you stop
and say "alright" ♪
♪ Oh, kinda spooky ♪
♪ With a spooky
little girl like you ♪